let's head to Wales should we wear
applied Camry is calling on voters there
to give them a similar voice in
Westminster is the SMP has managed to
secure four people in Scotland applied
Westminster leader list several Roberts
joins me now from below now for
synagogue in Snowdonia very good to see
you this morning
it's a very big ask isn't it when you've
got four seats at the moment and they're
all marginal - to ask for a similar sort
of standing as the SNP has in Scotland
is it's a very big challenge I think of
course we had four members of parliament
in the last Parliament I hope we'll have
four I hope we'll have five we may even
have more but the one thing that I would
say and of course anybody who watched
the the leaders debates last night would
have felt this - you know for an area
like Blaine of Estonia where we are
today
it's a post-industrial area used to be
very much the state industry now very
dependent on tourism and for Wales as a
whole and you listen to Boris Johnson
and Jeremy Corbyn last night and you
honestly feel that for areas like this
where is their voice and that's what I
am proud to say for the the four plied
MPs that we had in Wales we made sure
that areas you know Wales for us
obviously plaid Camry play company Wales
matters most for us it's in the name
it's easy to imagine but there are so
many places that are being disregarded
and there's one thing that for those
four MPs that we had in Westminster we
did something which the Tories have
never done and I'm afraid to say that
but that Jeremy Corbyn doesn't do either
we worked with other parties and we
worked with our parties to make sure the
legislation made went through that Boris
Johnson had to go back to negotiate with
Europe because although he's talking
about getting brexit done earlier this
year he would have been very happy to
get brexit done to mean to leave without
a deal but we work with others and we
made sure that for a place like Buena
Vista New York that voted to remain
Deauville merry on earth Gwyneth our
constituencies that voted to remain
that they had a fair voice in
Westminster yeah but that forgive me
that's that's a difficult line for
private Hungary to be pushing isn't it
when you look at Wales as a whole Wales
as a country voted for brexit you say
you're the voice for Wales you're not on
your knots are you such as such a strong
romaine party why aren't you listening
to what the people of Wales actually
said in 2016 just look back at the time
when Wales had the first opportunity to
vote for its own Parliament which is
something that play Camery adamantly
believed it believes in in 1979 people
of Wales did not vote for that
Parliament but we didn't give up because
that was our principle and that was our
belief that was the the core purpose if
you like to play camera at the time to
do the best for Wales and to make sure
that no damage is done to lions because
labour won't do that heaven knows labour
has been representing Wales for a
hundred years they've had power in the
assembly in Cardiff for 20 years and how
much the better are we for it
and we know we know Johnston's not going
to put the interests of Wales first now
we know that any form of brexit will do
damage to the the fragile economies of
places like Buena Vista nail-gun where
certain Phil across Wales we believe
that those are our principles that's why
we've worked with others in this
election to do something that is really
difficult political parties to work
together
thank you forgive me forgive me for
interrupting forgive me but what about
the people who turn around and say
actually what about the damage to
democracy if brexit isn't carried out
because people will rightly ask what is
the point of voting again in any future
referendum or indeed any election not my
thoughts the thoughts of Leanne would
your former leader well of course and
that's why my party is arguing for a
confirmatory referendum to use democracy
we're now three years and more down the
Leanne wood said the results echo enough
to be over
the question and the voters it stands
we've had the leave argument we must
move ahead of this tiny majority Boris
Johnson is abusing democracy in the way
he twists and turns the truth that is
the simple fact we need to remote our
democracy into the future we need to
bring this back to the people for this
major major choice that we're facing
presently but the one thing that I will
say going around this constituency but
across Wales as well is this sense that
Westminster is desperately failing our
communities and when you see the
argument last night
one man utterly lacking all conviction
and the other just saying half-truths
untruth unsubstantiated economic fantasy
there is a question in Wales now
Westminster okay you've told us you can
serve as well in the past but you're not
serving us well now the time does come
when we looked thing couldn't we do this
better ourselves
I'm slightly confused because you've
you've talked a lot about how important
it is that client has been prepared to
work with other parties yet you've just
described Jeremy Corbyn as being a man
utterly without conviction in the debate
last night if there is a hung parliament
or indeed a very narrow majority for the
Conservative Party I can't work out from
what you're saying whether applied would
be prepared to support Jeremy Corbyn to
prop him up in number 10 or not I'll
tell you one thing we would never
support Boris Johnson because go back
about two months and we were trying to
impeach him for his misuse of facts and
the truth his abuse of the truth when it
comes to working with others we will
work as a political party does on the
basis of issues not of personalities not
even necessarily a party interests our
priority in this election is to get a
complimentary referendum and then we
also have a set of costed proposals in
terms of revenue spend and
infrastructure spend in Wales that would
include electrifying the railways
looking at a new railway between
Carmarthen Nablus with a whole tranche
of proposals that would make people's
lives better here and the sort of spend
you need central government to do
make sure you have a decent economy in
these areas that have been left behind
taken for granted by labour and just
ignored by the torres liz sivell Rob
it's good to talk to you thank you